C'est une sensation unique.
Je ne connais rien de plus grisant.
Comme si tu pouvais voler.
Comme s'il te poussait des ailes.
Quand on a ça dans le sang,
on ne peut pas s'en passer.
Il en faut toujours plus.
Une fois les bouchons dans les oreilles,
le casque sur la tête, c'est le silence total.
Le reste du monde n'existe plus.
On pense uniquement à la course.
D'abord, mon esprit
se vide complètement.
Et ensuite, il se déchaîne.
Tout ça, c'est sans doute grâce
à M. Acum, mon instit en primaire.
Il ne plaisantait pas
avec les bonnes manières.
Il était de la vieille école.
Sacré bonhomme.
Si on n'était pas sages, il nous
donnait une fessée avec une pantoufle.
Il la faisait chauffer sur un radiateur
avant de s'en servir.
Et si ça ne suffisait pas,
on allait ramasser des cailloux,
pour faciliter le passage
de la tondeuse à gazon.
Il avait son propre terrain de golf
au fond de la cour,
et notre punition principale, c'était
de prendre soin de l'herbe du green.
Et ça me donnait envie de faire la course
avec la tondeuse.
Mon premier moteur venait
d'une Suffolk Punch.
Je dois encore l'avoir.
Je jouais tout le temps avec.
Je ne m'intéressais pas trop aux filles.
Aujourd'hui encore,
on ne peut pas dire
que ce soit une grande
préoccupation.
Je ne suis pas homosexuel.
Mais j'ai toujours préféré jouer
avec les camions et les moteurs,
et ça n'a pas vraiment changé.
Je suis resté un gamin.
- Tu as la clé ?
- Oui.
C'est parti.
Attention. Tu l'attrapes ?
La course sur route ?
C'est de la folie.
La vache, il est serré à fond.
Comment on pourrait dire ?
Une araignée au plafond ?
Un petit vélo dans la tête ?
Une case en moins ? Ça, je le dis
souvent. Il nous manque une vis.
Pour les non-initiés,
j'imagine que tous les pilotes
du Tourist Trophy,
il leur manque une vis.
Remporter une course au Trophy,
est une vraie consécration.
Moi, je n'ai pas encore réussi.
Mais je m'accroche.
Barry Sheene n'aimait pas ce circuit.
Il le trouvait trop dangereux.
Même lui avait un côté
petite nature, apparemment.
Bon, ici, c'est réglé. Alors ?
C'est mieux.
♪ ai vu Les Briseurs de Barrages
l'autre jour.
L'attaque avec les bombes
de Barnes Wallis.
Il en a eu l'idée à cause de...
C'était pas Napoléon.
Le gars avec les navires de guerre,
ça commence par un N.
Pas Napoléon.
On a tous des loisirs et des plaisirs
différents.
Je n'aime pas aller au bistrot.
Ou m'envoyer en l'air. Ça ne me
dérange pas, mais c'est pas mon truc.
Je préfère la moto ou le vélo.
C'est une question de goût.
Si on était pareils,
tout le monde participerait au TT.
Mais on a des motivations différentes.
Moi, c'est ça qui me motive,
et je continuerai jusqu'à
ce que je gagne une course.
Ou cinq.
En une semaine. Personne n'a
jamais réussi. Après, j'arrête,
et je me trouve
autre chose à faire.
♪ ai un autre objectif aussi.
Un truc énorme.
Enfin, non, j'exagère.
Ce n'est pas énorme.
On exagère toujours, quand on parle.
C'est comme quand on dit :
C'est incroyable.
Ça ne veut rien dire, "|ncroyab|e".
Le jour où je verrai
quelqu'un manger sa propre tête,
je dirai : "C'est incroyable."
Parce que franchement, je n'y crois pas.
Mais il ne faut jamais dire jamais.
Incroyable ! C'est vraiment incroyable !
Evel Knievel était le grand cascadeur
à l'époque.
♪ avais la tenue et le casque aux couleurs
du drapeau américain, comme lui.
Je me prenais pour lui.
Mon père avait fabriqué une rampe,
je sautais par-dessus 14 petits bus,
alors qu'Evel Knievel sautait
par-dessus 14 véritables bus.
Je lui ai écrit une lettre
pour demander à faire un saut avec lui,
mais je n'ai jamais reçu de réponse.
♪ ai toujours eu ça en moi. Aucun
autre sport ne m'intéresse vraiment.
Ça a toujours été les motos, rien d'autre.
John est resté un petit garçon au fond.
Il est un peu fou.
Quand je l'ai rencontré,
il avait arrêté le motocross,
et il voulait se mettre
à la moto de course.
Il a toujours dit : "Un jour, je ferai
le Tourist Trophy de l'lle de Man.
Je veux juste gagner une course.
Une seule.
Après, j'arrête."
Il a gagné sa 1re course en 250 cc,
et on s'est dit : "Dieu merci, c'est terminé."
Mais ça lui a juste donné encore
plus envie.
A 10 ans, je regardais déjà
cet évènement, ça me passionnait.
Je me disais : "Un jour,
je gagnerai une de ces courses."
Mais si on m'avait dit que
je remporterais 15 victoires,
je me serais sans doute moqué de lui.
Et pourtant, aujourd'hui, j'en suis là.
Mais j'ai toujours autant le trac
quand je me dis que la date du TT
approche. Je commence à angoisser
plusieurs mois avant la compétition.
Chaque fois que j'y pense,
j'ai un pincement au cœur.
Je me mets à ranger la maison
et le garage. Tout doit être à sa place.
Je tonds la pelouse,
je lave les voitures.
Histoire d'avoir tout prévu au cas
où il m'arriverait quelque chose.
♪ y pense de temps en temps,
évidemment. C'est inévitable.
C'est une réalité qu'il faut être
prêt à affronter.
Peut-être que je ne reviendrai pas.
John McGuinness, 17 minutes 43,
205,48 km/h, record du meilleur tour!
Chaque année,
des générations entières d'hommes
et de femmes ont fait ce pèlerinage
à Hle de Man pour se confronter
pendant deux semaines
à ce circuit
de renommée internationale,
synonyme de vitesse et de gloire.
A l'époque où la vitesse était limitée
à 30 km/h sur les routes anglaises,
et que les courses étaient interdites,
quelques passionnés de moto
ont voulu se mettre à l'épreuve,
jusqu'à repousser leurs limites
de vitesse et d'endurance.
Ils se sont réunis sur I'IIe de Man,
et c'est ainsi qu'en 1907,
le Tourist Trophy a vu le jour.
Vous voyez ? Regardez la suspension.
Vous voyez ?
Et si je fais ça.
Regardez.
C'est là que ça se passe.
Vous voyez ? C'est génial.
Guy et moi, on a une relation père-fils
très banale.
On veut toujours avoir raison.
Je vais faire chauffer de l'eau.
Ça, c'est un Steadicam.
Il doit y avoir des sortes
d'amortisseurs dedans.
C'est un système qui permet de filmer
à la main, sans que la caméra tremble.
C'est le principe, oui.
C'est pas donné, je parie ?
Ça coûte combien ce bras articulé ?
Quatorze.
- Quatorze quoi ?
- Quatorze mille livres.
Tu déconnes.
Quatorze mille balles ?
Quatorze mille !
♪ y crois pas...
Tiens, regarde ça.
Quatorze mille balles.
Mon premier Trophy, c'était en 1974.
Je pilotais
une Norton Commando Gus Kuhn.
Je croyais que j'allais être la star.
- Je suis parti de...
- Tu avais quel âge ?
♪ avais...
♪ avais quel âge ?
1974.
Ça fait combien ?
Je ne sais pas.
74 moins 47. Pas facile.
Bref.
Je passe Glen Helen, je grimpe la colline,
j'accélère, je descends la pente,
je ne vois plus la route,
je quitte la piste. La moto
s'est retrouvée en trois morceaux,
et je me suis cassé le dos.
Mais l'année d'après, j'y suis retourné.
Le pire accident que j'ai eu ?
C'était sans doute à North West, en 2008.
Juste après Black Hill,
l'avant de la moto est parti.
♪ ai décollé, etj'ai atterri
sur les fesses à 200 km/h.
Je n'ai rien eu,
mais la moto était morte,
complètement explosée.
Je m'en suis tiré,
mais ça m'a vraiment marqué...
Je me suis dit,
si jamais ça se reproduit...
A la moindre erreur,
c'est terminé.
Mais c'est exaltant aussi.
Je ne suis pas maso,
je n'essaie pas de me tuer.
Au contraire, je veux aller au bout
de la course.
Mais ce qui est grisant,
c'est ce danger permanent,
le risque de se planter à tout moment.
C'est une sensation vraiment unique.
Juste avant l'accident,
on ne ressent aucune panique.
On se dit juste : "C'est fini."
En dix ans de course,
ça m'est arrivé seulement quatre fois.
Dont trois fois au Tourist Trophy.
Je vais à la salle de sport deux fois
par semaine, et je vais faire du VTT
deux fois par semaine aussi.
♪ aime bien m'entraîner. Ça m'aide
à rester concentré sur mon objectif.
Et évidemment, ça me permet
aussi de ne pas perdre la main.
Je m'entraîne régulièrement,
c'est une habitude.
♪ ai toujours adoré les motos,
même si mes parents
trouvaient ça dangereux.
A l'âge de 15 ans, j'ai réussi à
les convaincre de m'en acheter une.
Ils ne voulaient pas que je conduise
une moto de course,
alors ils m'ont acheté une petite
moto de trial. Mais dès que j'ai eu 17 ans,
j'ai passé mon permis, et je me suis
acheté une moto de course.
♪ ai rencontré une bande de jeunes
qui avaient récupéré une vieille caravane,
en piteux état, et on a fait le tour du pays.
On allait voir des compétitions,
on faisait des barbecues,
on participait à des courses.
C'était une expérience vraiment
formidable.
Les aptitudes naturelles permettent
d'atteindre un certain niveau.
Mais je ne veux surtout pas me retrouver
dans une course très serrée,
et perdre parce que je ne serai
pas suffisamment en forme.
Ce serait vraiment terrible pour moi.
L'entraînement est un peu une obsession.
Je n'ai qu'une seule idée en tête.
Gagner la course.
Les 60 kilomètres de route qui
composent ce circuit ont donné
autant d'occasions aux pilotes
de devenir des champions et des héros.
Ils doivent franchir le plus vite possible
plus de 200 virages, pour remporter
la course la plus difﬁcile du monde,
pouvant totaliser jusqu ‘à 6 tours.
Pendant la semaine du Trophy, 5 courses
ont lieu, dont la célèbre Senior TT.
Les pilotes peuvent
atteindre 320 km/h
sur des routes où chaque virage
peut constituer un danger mortel.
Entre 1911 et 2010, 231 pilotes
ont perdu la vie sur ce circuit impitoyable.
Remporter une seule course du TT
est un exploit considérable.
Le champion absolu est le légendaire
Joey Dunlop, qui totalise 26 victoires.
John McGuinness détient le record
du meilleur tour,
et Phil McCallen est le seul pilote
à avoir remporté quatre courses sur cinq
durant la même année.
Personne n'a encore gagné
les cinq courses.
Voici notre cher mécanicien, Guy Martin.
Le costume n'est pas revenu
du pressing ?
On me reproche de ne pas
bien m'exprimer,
de ne pas m'habiller convenablement.
Ça m'agace un peu,
car c'est beaucoup moins drôle.
Alors que Wilson est d'accord avec moi.
Le but, c'est de s'amuser et de gagner.
Pour moi,
c'est comme David et Goliath.
C'est ça qui me motive énormément.
Guy intègre une petite équipe,
mais il peut gagner.
On n'a pas vraiment signé
de contrat, tous les deux.
Juste une bonne poignée de mains.
Disons que c'était un accord tacite
entre deux hommes respectables.
Moi, un homme respectable ?
Il y a pire que toi.
Il y a beaucoup mieux aussi.
Tu te souviens
quand je me paluchais ?
Souvent, je me réveillais
et tu étais en pleine action.
Je me recouchais,
le temps que tu finisses.
- Tu dormais juste au-dessus de moi.
- En effet.
Je l'ai réalisé après
ma fracture de la cheville.
- Oui ?
- Tes orteils bougeaient.
Quand je me paluchais.
- Je voyais ses orteils bouger.
- Et là, tu savais.
Je te laissais
quelques minutes.
Oui, le temps de finir.
Dans les semaines qui précèdent
le Trophy, chaque course
donne l'occasion d'améliorer sa moto,
de séduire de nouveaux sponsors,
et de perfectionner ses réflexes
pour la grande épreuve de |'||e de Man.
On n'est pas là
pour battre des records de vitesse,
ou pour gagner la course.
Le but, c'est de tester la moto.
Il me faut être un bon mécanicien.
Je suis un peu difficile,
j'ai des exigences très précises.
Beaucoup de pilotes enfourchent
leur moto et mettent les gaz.
Mais moi, j'ai besoin
de connaître ma moto à fond.
Je veux comprendre
le fonctionnement au niveau mécanique
pour prévoir
les réactions de la moto.
On ne peut pas foncer bêtement
sans se soucier des conséquences.
On risque d'abîmer
quelque chose
si on ne fait pas attention.
Personne qui pourrait
nous passer un autre embrayage ?
La pire crainte de tous les pilotes,
c'est la défaillance mécanique.
Il arrive qu'un composant lâche
quand le moteur s'emballe.
Et ce genre de chose ne pardonne pas.
Surtout au Tourist Trophy,
parce qu'au moindre accident,
il faut attendre un an
pour retenter sa chance.
Chris Mehew
est un véritable héros.
Il est un peu fou, mais très gentil.
Il aime beaucoup les chiens,
il leur parle tout le temps.
Et il adore les vieilles pendules.
Il fait du vin. Il a une vigne
dans son jardin qui pousse
jusque dans sa véranda.
Il a fait un trou dans le mur
pour la laisser passer.
Il cueille le raisin
pour faire son propre vin.
On ne voit pas ça souvent, non ?
♪ ai participé au Trophy en 1973.
Deux courses, deux accidents.
En fait, j'ai passé plus de temps
à l'hôpital que sur la piste.
Je récupère des moteurs de série,
et j'en fais des moteurs de course.
Ma plus grande fierté,
c'était pour les 100 ans du Trophy.
Tous les vainqueurs avaient un moteur
qui venait de mon atelier.
Je pense que Guy a la meilleure
moto possible.
Je ferai de mon mieux,
et il peaufinera derrière, évidemment.
S'il en est satisfait, ça marchera.
Je suis confiant.
Avec un peu de chance,
on aura de bons résultats.
Mais il ne faut pas qu'on se dise
que c'est notre tour.
Ce n'est jamais
le tour de personne.
Il faut avoir les bons ingrédients
et les utiliser intelligemment.
Les pilotes ont une dernière occasion
de préparer leurs motos
lors des courses du North West 200
sur les routes d'lrlande du Nord.
Tout le monde est prêt
pour le début de la course.
Ça y est, ils sont partis !
Michael Dunlop
se distingue déjà !
On peut le voir sur les images,
il va arriver
en haut de la colline
dans quelques instants.
- 265 km/h !
- Ça, c'est du virage !
Michael Dunlop et son frère William
représentent la nouvelle génération
d'une dynastie de pilotes qui
a commencé avec leur oncle Joey
et leur père Robert Dunlop.
C'étaient les plus grands pilotes
de course au monde, je pense.
Ils m'ont énormément inspiré.
On les décrit souvent
comme des héros ou des stars,
mais j'ai grandi avec eux,
c'étaient des gens normaux pour moi.
Age' de 49 ans, Joey n'a fait
qu'une bouchée de ses adversaires
lors du Trophy de l'an 2000,
en réalisant son 3e "hat trick".
Il a perdu la vie trois semaines plus tard,
lors d'une course peu connue en Estonie.
Plus de 50 000 personnes
ont assisté à son enterrement.
Son frère Robert a failli mourir
lors du Trophy de 1998
dans un accident causé
par sa roue arrière.
Mais il a continué les courses de moto
jusqu'à sa mort en 2008,
pendant le tour d'essai
du North West 200.
Il connaissait le circuit, mais
il y a eu une défaillance mécanique.
Ça arrive même aux meilleurs.
Une grande perte pour le sport,
et pour nous.
Mais ce samedi-là,
j'ai eu envie de piloter la 250 cc.
Deux jours après la mort de son père,
Michael a remporté la course,
dans un moment chargé d'émotion.
Impossible d'imaginer
ce qu'il ressent.
C'était beaucoup plus
qu'une simple course.
♪ étais très jeune à l'époque,
et je ne pensais qu'à m'amuser.
On n'est jamais vraiment préparé
à ce genre d'évènement.
♪ ai dû passer à l'âge adulte
en très peu de temps.
♪ espère qu'ils sont là-haut,
et qu'ils sont heureux.
Conor Cummins !
Conor Cummins, le pilote de |'||e de Man !
Il est à pleine vitesse.
Cummins est à terre !
♪ ai dépassé Ryan,
et en sortant du virage,
l'arrière de la moto s'est dérobée,
et je suis passé par-dessus le guidon.
♪ ai eu beaucoup de chance,
je m'en suis tiré presque
sans une égratignure.
Et du coup,
j'ai participé
à la course suivante.
Quand on tombe de cheval,
on se remet en selle.
Guy aussi a eu son lot
de mauvaises chutes.
Je vais bien.
C'est pas grave.
C'est juste une éraflure.
Et mon doigt a pris un peu aussi.
Je me suis déconcentré.
Trop de choses à gérer,
c'était ma faute.
Je me suis pris le bord,
et je me suis retrouvé dans l'herbe.
La moto n'a pas souffert,
on a changé...
- On a changé quoi ?
- Des composants sur le moteur.
Des composants sur le moteur.
Plus de peur que de mal.
De la fumée. C'est Guy Martin.
Son moteur est cassé.
Pendant la deuxième course, Guy part
en surrégime, et son moteur lâche.
C'est fini pour lui.
On n'a pas obtenu
de très bons résultats.
Ça ne s'est pas complètement
passé comme prévu.
C'est le moins qu'on puisse dire.
Mais ça nous permet de s'améliorer.
On n'est jamais trop vieux
pour apprendre.
Le point positif,
c'est que Guy ira au Trophy
avec deux nouveaux moteurs,
flambants neufs.
Au niveau de la vitesse,
on peut mieux faire, mais ça va.
La stabilité est bonne,
la tenue de route aussi.
Il y a quelques problèmes
mais on s'en sort bien.
♪ ai réservé le ferry
et j'y vais avec le camping-car.
C'est ça ou rester
à la maison, à attendre
que le téléphone sonne
Autant être sur place, près de lui.
Depuis plus de 100 ans,
les passionnés de moto se rassemblent
sur l'lle de Man pour regarder
leurs héros affronter le circuit du Trophy.
Ces pilotes d'exception très soudés ne
participent pas pour remporter le modeste
prix du Tournoi,
mais pour l'amour du sport
et la gloire de la victoire.
Les habitants de |'||e de Man
grandissent au milieu
des motos et des courses.
C'est une province rurale tranquille,
avec de calmes routes de campagne.
Et soudain, ces routes
voient passer tous ces motards,
et c'est comme si l'île prenait vie.
C'est formidable.
Toutes ces histoires,
ces parcours de vie
qui culminent lors
de cette glorieuse course.
C'est un festival,
un grand rassemblement
des amoureux de la moto.
On se raconte les anecdotes,
assis sur les talus à travers l'île
toute entière. Ces histoires
reprennent vie chaque année.
On ne se lasse jamais de les raconter.
Aux Etats-Unis, il y a beaucoup
d'adeptes de la moto
qui connaissent bien le Tourist Trophy,
comme moi.
Et cet événement figure
sur leur liste de choses
à voir avant de mourir.
De se rendre au TT.
C'est pour ça que je suis là,
j'ai toujours voulu voir ça.
Mon père et moi évoquions souvent
la possibilité d'y aller, sans jamais le faire.
Il est décédé, mais j'ai enfin pu venir,
et je partagerai
la chose avec lui
d'une manière ou d'une autre.
Ça fait 27 ans que je viens
habillé comme ça,
et dans 27 ans, je serai ici,
avec les mêmes vêtements.
Je m'appelle Karen Anderson,
et je viens d'Australie
pour voir participer Cameron Donald.
On s'installait en haut, sur le balcon,
et on regardait les pilotes
passant devant la maison.
Il y avait un lampadaire, juste devant.
Quand ils arrivaient, ils se penchaient,
et ils faisaient ça
pour éviter le lampadaire.
Et à chaque fois,
je retenais ma respiration.
Encore et encore.
C'était génial.
Oui, je sais ce qu'on risque.
Mais avec ma femme,
pas d'excès de vitesse,
sinon je me prends une rouste.
C'est vraiment dangereux,
ça va très vite.
On vient voir les hommes
les plus courageux du monde.
Si vous n'êtes pas emballés par ce
spectacle, c'est que vous êtes insensible.
Ça, c'est sûr.
A peine arrivé,
Guy veut modifier la suspension,
et notamment le bras oscillant,
qui est crucial pour changer
rapidement la roue.
Wilson. Il faut mettre
l'autre bras oscillant,
et changer la roue.
C'est de la daube,
et ça va poser problème.
Si c'était moi qui récupérais la moto,
on éviterait ce genre de problème.
Je l'avais dit dès le début.
Les autorités n'apprécient pas
que Guy travaille sur sa moto
hors du paddock.
Je savais qu'il y aurait des tensions.
♪ ai un matelas gonflable
dans ma camionnette.
Si la moto n'est pas préparée
exactement comme je le veux,
je remballe tout et je rentre.
Je ne vais pas risquer ma vie
si tout ne va pas bien.
Je suis très pointilleux.
Mais on va s'arranger.
Je ne peux pas en faire qu'à ma tête,
car Wilson a acheté les motos.
Il a investi beaucoup d'argent.
Mais je les pilote,
et je dois avoir l'esprit tranquille.
Wilson l'a dit depuis le début.
Mais pour que j'aie l'esprit tranquille,
il faut que je puisse
m'occuper de mes motos
sans être dérangé.
Je vais m'arranger avec Wilson.
Les motos devront être de retour
à une heure bien précise,
et je devrai faire quelques courbettes
aux bonnes personnes pour que ça passe.
On a un contrat. On nous accorde
une certaine somme d'argent,
Guy est censé se conduire
de manière professionnelle.
Mais certaines de ses remarques
ne plaisent pas à tout le monde.
C'est peut-être ce côté rebelle
qui plaît tant au public.
Il faut qu'on fasse avec.
Si je lui dicte sa conduite,
ça ne marchera pas.
C'est à la fois un mécanicien,
et un formidable pilote.
Même quand les motos sont prêtes, il a
besoin d'apporter sa touche personnelle.
Je lui ai accordé tout ce qu'il demandait.
Alors, il faut que ça marche cette fois.
On fera une vérification supplémentaire
de la moto, et ensuite,
ça ne dépendra plus de nous.
Ce virage-là est crucial.
Si on le négocie correctement,
on peut gagner dix secondes,
parce qu'après,
on n'a pas besoin de freiner
ou de relâcher les gaz
pendant 5 kilomètres.
Mais c'est un virage très difficile.
"Balla-scaw."
Ballagarey.
Je viens de voir le panneau.
Ce virage, il ne pardonne pas.
Mais il ne faut pas y penser.
Pour atteindre une vitesse suffisante,
il faut mettre plein gaz, comme on dit.
Voici la météo, le ciel devrait
se couvrir vers la fin de la matinée,
mais dans l'ensemble, le temps
restera sec sur l'ensemble de l'île.
Ça va, chef? Super.
Cette année, Guy Martin aura beaucoup
de concurrents sérieux.
Cameron Donald a toujours
été une vraie menace.
Il a un tempérament nerveux,
mais il est très rapide.
Il y a aussi Conor Cummins.
Conor vit sur l'île, il est jeune,
et en pleine forme.
Ryan Farquhar.
Il a battu le record de victoires
de Joey Dunlop en Irlande.
Il est phénoménal.
Les frères Dunlop
ne se laisseront pas faire.
Michael est très agressif,
et il fera tout pour gagner.
Je n'aimerais pas Paffronter sur un ring.
Keith Amor est comme un chien
en laisse.
Il tire le plus fort possible
jusqu'à arriver au bout de la course.
Bruce est imprévisible. S'il se lève
le matin avec l'envie de battre
tout le monde, il y arrivera sans doute.
Et John McGuinness
est la star du moment.
C'est lui qui a les meilleurs résultats.
Quand on bat son record,
il accélère un peu,
- et il repasse devant.
- Personne ne connaît les vraies limites
de John. Il n'a jamais eu besoin
d'aller aussi loin.
Il ne faut sous-estimer personne.
On peut toujours se retrouver face
à un pilote qui sort de nulle part,
et qui surprend.
Je ne sais pas grand-chose
sur Hutchinson.
C'est un sportif plutôt discret.
Il fait ce qu'il a à faire.
On dirait moi, il y a dix ans.
Il enregistre tout,
il sait ce que ça demande
de gagner une telle course.
Et Guy. On dirait que toute le monde
veut le voir gagner.
Il gagnera certainement
l'une des 5 courses,
il a suffisamment de talent pour ça.
Mais j'ai l'impression
qu'il lui manque un petit truc.
Mais au bout du compte,
c'est le meilleur qui gagnera.
Et personne ne désire cette victoire
plus que moi.
Le danger augmente avec la vitesse,
c'est pourquoi
le Trophy ne fait plus partie du circuit
international des Grand Prix Moto.
Mais pour remporter l'une des cinq
courses, il ne suffit pas d'être rapide.
Il faut une mécanique parfaite,
une endurance mentale
et physique extrême,
une bonne dose de chance,
et des arrêts au stand très courts.
Un plein et une paire de pneus
ne durent que
deux tours sur quatre ou six.
Le temps total dépend beaucoup
de ces arrêts au stand,
qui peuvent faire la différence
entre victoire et défaite.
- Trente-trois secondes.
- Bien joué !
Avec une seule erreur,
on monte à quarante.
Le bras oscillant sur ma moto ne permet
pas de faire un arrêt rapide au stand.
Ma moto de l'année dernière
a été vendue à un habitant
de l'île, et je l'ai supplié
de me prêter le bras oscillant.
Il m'a dit : "Pas de problème."
Je vais aller le récupérer
cet après-midi.
Et demain matin,
on pourra l'installer
sur ma nouvelle moto.
Ça me rendrait bien service.
Le père de Guy a décidé
de ne pas venir cette année.
C'est un coup dur
que mon père ne soit pas là.
Il est toujours de bon conseil, car il a
quinze ans d'expérience au Trophy.
Il sait exactement comment il faut
que ça se passe.
Je serais plus confiant s'il était là.
Je peux m'en sortir, mais sans lui,
ça va être beaucoup plus difficile.
Ça me perturbe un peu.
Mais je n'y peux rien,
il faut faire avec.
Martin Finnegan était un pilote,
et un ami très proche,
j'étais à son mariage.
C'était en novembre 2007, je crois.
Oui, c'est ça, 2007.
Et son enterrement, c'était...
en avril 2008.
Un de mes coéquipiers, Darren
Lindsay, est mort en 2005.
Il y a aussi Richard Britton, je réparais
ses moteurs, il est mort en 2006.
Et ainsi de suite.
Alors, je me dis...
Quand ton heure est venue...
Dans ce genre de boulot,
il faut s'y préparer.
C'est pour ça que je ne prends
aucun engagement.
Si j'avais une femme, des enfants,
et une maison à payer,
je ne pourrais pas faire
ces compétitions.
Je ne pourrais pas m'investir à fond.
Avant même de penser à gagner
une course,
il faut faire les tours d'essai.
On en a cinq à faire.
Il va falloir modifier pas mal
de choses sur les bécanes.
C'est là que mon père
aurait pu m'aider.
Ça va demander pas mal de bricolage
pour installer l'autre bras oscillant.
Mais si c'était facile,
tout le monde le ferait, pas vrai ?
Ensuite, j'irai me reposer un peu.
Tous les soirs,
je trouve un nouvel endroit pour me garer,
et je gonfle le matelas.
Une petite branlette, et au lit.
Tranquille.
Les gens sont toujours choqués,
mais c'est pas un crime.
Y a pas de mal à ça.
Il ne faut jamais
se reposer sur ses lauriers.
Il y a toujours quelque chose
à apprendre,
et toujours des occasions
de se planter.
♪ ai pris un petit moment pour aller
regarder la route.
Ils l'ont déjà fermée.
On entendait seulement les bruits
des oiseaux.
C'est un aspect vraiment unique
de ce circuit.
Et je me disais :
"La semaine prochaine,
je descendrai cette route
à 320 à l'heure."
Ce qu'on ressent, quand on vient
se placer sur la ligne de départ
de la course, les uns après les autres,
c'est vraiment...
C'est incroyable.
Je n'ai jamais rien connu de tel.
On n'affronte pas les autres pilotes.
On affronte le circuit.
Le Trophy est la course la plus intense
qu'on puisse connaître.
♪ adore ça. Et c'est légal.
On me demande pourquoi
je fais des courses sur route.
Sur un circuit, on va vite,
c'est exaltant, mais ce n'est pas pareil.
C'est comme faire de l'escalade
avec une corde.
C'est dangereux,
mais on peut se tromper.
Si on tombe, la corde nous retient.
La route, c'est sans filet.
On escalade exactement
la même montagne,
mais on n'a pas le droit à l'erreur.
Le moindre faux pas, et c'est fini.
On risque des blessures graves,
ou pire.
On fait du 275 ou 290 à l'heure,
on enchaîne les virages, les arbres,
les murs de briques.
C'est génial.
On est conscient du danger avant
de monter sur la moto.
Au départ,
quand on regarde la route devant soi,
on a plein de choses
qui nous traversent l'esprit.
On angoisse.
Mais dès que le signal du départ
est donné, on met les gaz,
et tout ça disparaît. Une fois
qu'on est lancé, le bruit, le vent,
l'effort physique.
C'est vraiment incroyable
ce qu'on s'inflige pendant cette course.
On se fait des frayeurs sans arrêt.
Mais c'est ça qui est grisant.
On ne peut pas faire semblant.
On n'a pas le choix.
C'est comme ça.
Surtout en deux-roues.
Il n'y a rien de plus difficile.
Dans le monde du sport,
il n'y a rien de plus extrême
que la course sur route.
Il suffit d'une fraction de seconde.
Même des gens comme Joey Dunlop,
avec ses 31 ans de carrière,
26 victoires au Trophy,
les Championnats du monde.
Il a suffi d'une fraction de seconde.
Aucune erreur n'est permise.
C'est le circuit le plus difficile
et le plus dangereux au monde.
Avec quatre fois plus de morts
que de kilomètres sur ce parcours.
Seuls quelques chanceux ont
survécu sans dommages à une chute.
Milky Quayle en fait partie.
C'est tellement exaltant que notre vie
toute entière tourne autour du Trophy,
qu'on soit sur la piste ou non.
Effectivement, ça peut être mortel.
Je sais que ça a l'air dingue,
mais ça fait huit ou neuf ans
que je n'ai pas participé à cette course,
et j'ai l'impression de ne plus
avoir de repères dans la vie.
Je n'arrive pas à retrouver
ce sentiment d'ivresse.
♪ ai l'impression d'avoir atteint
le summum à l'époque,
j'ai du mal à m'en passer.
C'est un peu comme une addiction.
Tu ne peux pas t'en défaire,
tu en veux plus.
Quand j'assiste à la course,
je voudrais être à leur place,
je me dis : "oui, fonce..."
Il faut trouver d'autres occupations,
le jardinage, le ménage.
Parfois, j'accueille les pilotes,
les invités, les journalistes.
Comme ça,
je pense un peu à autre chose.
Miiky s'occupe
des participants novices.
Il leur faut trois ans
de compétition pour apprivoiser
le circuit et acquérir suffisamment
d'assurance
pour repousser leurs limites.
Il faut avoir confiance en soi,
et savoir comment négocier
chaque virage pour
gagner de la vitesse.
J'en suis encore à essayer
pour aller de plus en plus vite
à chaque fois.
Je m'habitue aux formes des virages,
aux bosses, aux pentes,
et avec un peu de chance,
je continuerai à améliorer ma vitesse.
On se couche !
On passe la haie,
et on bascule de l'autre côté.
On coupe le virage,
et il y en a un autre juste derrière.
Il faut trois ans
pour le faire correctement.
Après seulement deux participations,
Jenny Tinmouth est la femme pilote
la plus rapide de l'histoire du circuit.
♪ ai l'impression
de ne pas être à ma place.
C'est étrange.
On se sent très téméraire, presque
insolent, quand on fonce sur les routes.
Mais ça fait partie du jeu.
Quand on descend Bray HiII,
on a le sourire jusqu'aux oreilles.
Arrivé là, je me concentre
sur le prochain virage, Ballagarey.
On le surnomme "Balla-scary",
ce qui veut dire effrayant.
C'est vraiment un virage très rapide.
C'est le plus important,
mais aussi le plus dangereux du circuit.
Ce qui le rend si difficile,
c'est qu'on ne le voit pas venir.
Là, j'arrive à toute vitesse,
je continue,
et quand je vois le panneau
de limitation de vitesse,
je lève le pied, et je rétrograde.
C'est le moment le plus délicat,
je vais devoir tourner,
mais je ne vois toujours pas le virage.
Ça vire à droite,
mais quand le guidon ?
Dès que je vois l'intérieur du virage,
je me couche et je tourne.
Et on passe au ras du trottoir.
Ça va tellement vite.
Avec une vitesse moyenne
de 211,75 km/h,
John McGuinness reste le pilote
le plus rapide du circuit.
Il y a cent ans, les premiers participants
n'allaient qu'à 61 km/h.
Depuis cette époque, même les pilotes
qui n'ont aucune chance de gagner,
viennent pour battre
leurs propres records.
Ils essaient continuellement
de diminuer le temps nécessaire
pour faire un tour complet.
On y est toujours un peu accro.
Une fois qu'on y a goûté,
on ne peut pas s'arrêter.
Chaque fois, on essaie de faire
le meilleur temps au tour possible.
Je me battais contre moi-même,
pas contre les autres.
Tous les ans, j'essayais de faire mieux.
Et j'y arrivais,
jusqu'à mon accident
malheureusement.
Ce n'était pas de ma faute,
c'était vraiment un coup de malchance.
Pendant le Trophy de 2009,
alors que Nick menait la course
avec son side-car,
il a heurté un lièvre
à plus de 250 km/h.
Il a surgi devant moi. Je l'ai percuté,
et ensuite, je me le suis pris
en pleine tête.
Là, c'était terminé.
Le side-car a viré à droite,
droit dans les arbres.
On a eu de la chance de s'en tirer.
Chaque fois que l'un de nos pilotes
se blesse ou se tue,
j'ai envie de tout arrêter.
Parfois, j'ai l'impression d'être
un trafiquant de drogue,
parce que je prépare ces engins
et qu'ils se font du mal
avec ce que je leur vends.
Heureusement, ça n'a jamais
été ma faute, je touche du bois.
Les pires, ce sont ceux qui vendent
la drogue,
pas ceux qui la consomment.
L'année dernière, j'avais décidé
d'arrêter les side-cars.
Mais Nick a remonté la pente
de manière incroyable,
et je ne pouvais pas lui dire non.
Alors je lui prépare
de nouveaux moteurs.
Il garde le moral,
c'est extraordinaire.
Nick ne pilotera pas
cette année.
Mais son équipe va tenter
de battre son record
du meilleur tour en side-car,
qui est resté invaincu
depuis son accident.
Tu cherches Guy ?
C'est à propos de sa licence. Gary,
tu as eu un problème avec ta licence ?
Oui, j'ai dû la re-scanner.
Évidemment, Guy est introuvable.
Sans une licence conforme,
il ne pourra pas participer aux essais.
Il faut attendre son retour pour
faire passer ses motos au contrôle.
On ignore où il est,
comme d'habitude.
Il ne devrait pas tarder, j'espère.
Guy Martin est attendu d'urgence
au bureau des courses. Merci.
Guy Martin. Par où commencer ?
C'est un rebelle,
un excentrique.
Il a toujours un bon mot à dire,
mais en général,
ça ne peut pas passer à la télé.
Il est un peu de la vieille école.
Il nous rappelle notre jeunesse.
Il a vraiment une personnalité unique.
Pour moi,
il ne sait pas ce qu'il veut faire,
il est trop dispersé.
♪ aimerais le voir gagner,
mais je ne sais pas s'il en est capable.
Guy est un sacré personnage,
il aime faire parler de lui.
Ça fait deux ans qu'il porte
ce short vert,
ça doit sentir le moisi là-dedans.
Mais les personnages hauts en couleur
font partie de l'univers des courses.
Il raconte n'importe quoi,
mais il est drôle.
Guy dit les choses comme elles sont.
C'est pour ça que les gens l'aiment.
Il n'a pas peur de se mettre la hiérarchie
à dos. Il est fidèle à lui-même,
et personne ne voudrait
qu'il en soit autrement.
C'est un gars qui a du cran. C'est
le John Wayne des courses de moto.
Enﬁn, Guy revient, après avoir
démoli la moto d'un ami
dans le sud de l'île.
- Et voilà, c'est réglé.
- Génial ! Merci, bonne journée !
Les routes seront fermées dans
une demi-heure, et les essais
commenceront à 19h30.
Maintenant que la licence de Guy
est validée, les motos peuvent
passer le contrôle.
Il est 19h25, les routes vont être fermées.
L'essai commence dans 5 minutes.
Cinq minutes, mesdames et messieurs.
Guy Martin, numéro 8,
et James Hillier, numéro 19,
quittent la ligne de départ à leur tour.
Les paris sont ouverts.
L'année dernière, les mécaniciens
m'ont dit qu'en arrivant au stand,
j'avais les yeux exorbités.
Le corps humain n'est pas habitué à
la violence qu'il subit durant cette course.
Tout va tellement vite.
Dès le premier tour,
j'atteins les 200 à l'heure.
C'est vraiment de la folie.
C'est vraiment spectaculaire.
Quand on dévale les routes sur
son vélo, on se prend pour un pilote
légendaire. Mais toutes les motos
de course qui passent,
c'est vraiment un autre niveau.
Ceux qui sont venus en moto
ce matin
roulaient à 65 km/h maximum.
Là, ils y vont plein gaz.
Ils dépassent les 300 à l'heure,
et ils slaloment
entre les murs de pierre et les haies,
alors il faut s'habituer à la vitesse.
Ensuite, on se détend un peu.
On se sent plus à l'aise sur le circuit.
On va plus vite, on pilote mieux,
on respire mieux.
C'est un état d'esprit particulier.
On dirait que tout ralentit.
On ne regarde plus les choses
de la même manière.
Notre cerveau se met à prévoir
les manœuvres sans qu'on y pense.
On anticipe les 4 ou 5
prochains virages.
On doit conserver un certain élan,
un certain rythme,
et éviter de rentrer
dans des duels stupides.
Il faut se servir de sa tête.
Je ne suis pas un concurrent très
agréable. Ceux qui veulent me battre
doivent être prêts à me suivre,
quitte à se prendre le mur.
C'est comme ça que je pilote.
C'est ma manière de faire, et si
les gens sont prêts à prendre ce risque,
alors je les attends de pied ferme.
On entend les motos arriver à fond,
en sixième.
Ils ne décélèrent pratiquement jamais.
♪ ai fait de la course pendant des années,
et c'est toujours aussi impressionnant.
Même après tout ce temps,
j'ai littéralement la chair de poule
chaque fois que je pense
au Tourist Trophy.
Je n'oublierai jamais mon premier
passage à l'intersection
de Saint-Ninian,
en descendant Bray Hill.
C'était comme si j'arrivais
au bout du monde,
et que je décollais d'une falaise.
On a vraiment l'impression de voler.
Et c'est le cas, pour ainsi dire.
Johnny. Tu sais où est Guy ?
- Où est-il ?
- Il arrive.
Le comité a saisi la moto de Guy,
car il l'a utilisée pour faire
un tour en ville illégalement.
Ils vont me passer un savon pour quoi
au juste ?
Tu n'avais pas le droit
de te promener en ville.
C'est écrit là. Tu étais censé lire
ça avant de partir,
mais tu étais pressé
parce que tu étais en retard.
Ne recommence pas.
C'est là que tu interviens ?
En tant que chef d'équipe ?
Je vais dire que c'est ta faute.
C'est de ta faute.
Génial ! Rob, tu es où ?
Vous en avez de plus en plus ?
- Chaque année.
- Bien.
Guy récupérera sa moto
après s'être excusé.
C'est où, le bureau des savons ?
Je peux reprendre ma moto ?
- Vous voulez des frites ?
- Je veux bien.
Je sais que vous avez un régime strict.
Merci.
Pas de problème.
- Toi, je t'aime bien.
- Merci, messieurs.
De rien, M. Craig.
Et voilà. C'est fait.
Ça ne va pas être de la tarte.
Pour le pignon, c'est pareil ?
Ça ne dure que deux semaines,
mais c'est quelque chose de vraiment...
Pour moi,
ceci est comme la Coupe du Monde.
C'est cinquante ans de ma vie,
c'est une centaine de semaines.
C'est vraiment incroyable.
L'ambiance unique, les amis que
je me suis fait, venant d'un peu partout,
et que je revoie tous les ans.
C'est vraiment un monde à part.
Une seconde !
On me dit souvent que je ne devrais
pas laisser Dan participer à cette course,
car on a des enfants.
Mais si je lui interdisais ça,
ce serait la fin du monde pour lui.
Je ne peux pas lui faire ça.
C'est mon mari, je l'aime,
et je dois le soutenir.
On est dans les tribunes
avec les femmes des autres pilotes
et leur famille. On est tous très inquiets,
mais on a besoin de faire
des blagues et de rire.
Au fond de nous-mêmes,
on trouve la force
de surmonter cette épreuve
tous ensemble.
On se soutient mutuellement.
Tous les pilotes ont la même manière
de se protéger.
Ils se disent tous :
"Ça ne m'arrivera jamais"
Mais au fond, ils savent
que ça peut très bien leur arriver.
Chacun a sa propre méthode
pour aller de l'avant.
♪ ai le même casque depuis 11 ans,
et je porte toujours une paire de
chaussettes bien précise pendant
deux semaines.
Je glisse aussi un sous dans ma veste
avant le début
de chaque course.
Ça n'apporte rien.
Mais je mettrais
une petite culotte rose
si ça me permettait de gagner.
Votre badge, s'il vous plaît.
- J'en ai pas.
- Il vous faut un badge.
- Mais j'en ai pas.
- Alors vous ne pouvez pas entrer.
- Sérieux ?
- C'est le règlement.
Je ne peux pas vous laisser passer.
C'est ce badge qu'il vous faut.
Je te le redonne à travers la barrière,
d'accord ? Voilà. Merci.
Le Tourist Trophy de l'lle de Man,
c'est le dernier bastion du libre choix.
C'est vraiment appréciable de voir
qu'ici, on accueille à bras ouverts
une activité qui serait interdite
presque partout ailleurs,
à cause des risques qu'elle représente.
On est des êtres humains.
La vie n'est pas un échauffement.
C'est un tour de piste.
Alors, autant qu'il soit génial.
Là, j'attaque la grande montée.
Je ralentis un peu,
je rétrograde en seconde.
Je longe le mur,
je passe le virage,
je redresse, et j'accélère.
Je reprends de la vitesse,
en attendant le prochain,
qui est très serré.
Je maintiens la vitesse,
je longe le mur, je lève le pied,
je rétrograde.
♪ anticipe le prochain virage,
je me couche, je me redresse.
Et là, je mets les gaz.
Je passe encore un virage,
je redresse la moto,
et j'accélère
en suivant bien la route.
Je gagne de la vitesse.
Je m'oriente légèrement vers la droite,
et je monte vers Guthries
Cette zone, c'est la troisième
plus importante du circuit.
Là, j'ai trois virages serrés à gauche.
♪ attaque le premier,
je redresse, je traverse
la ligne blanche, j'attaque le deuxième,
puis le troisième, et là,
je ralentis, et je rétrograde.
Je redresse, j'accélère à nouveau,
je traverse la ligne blanche
pour être du bon côté de la route,
puis je repasse de l'autre côté,
et j'accélère à fond.
Parfait. Ça va tout seul.
C'est un vrai bonheur.
Bang.
Au cours des sept prochains jours, les
pilotes connaîtront bien des souffrances.
Sept vertèbres fracturées,
quatre côtes cassées,
cinq accidents graves,
deux poumons endommagés,
et malheureusement, bien pire.
Où est Camee ?
Il est là ? C'est quoi le programme ?
Quoi ? Il prend le thé.
Et on se prépare à se lever tôt.
- C'est ça, Wilson ?
- Pardon ?
Ils nous demandent
quel est le programme.
Tu prends ta moto, et tu fonces.
Voilà. C'est pas compliqué.
Un peu de brouillard, mais les hauteurs
sont relativement dégagées.
On commence avec la course Superbike.
Six tours de circuit,
364,32 kilomètres.
C'est une épreuve contre la montre. Les
pilotes partent à dix secondes d'intervalle.
Ils affrontent leurs concurrents,
mais aussi le chronomètre,
et bien évidemment eux-mêmes.
Ils se mesurent à ce parcours
légendaire, et à son histoire.
Dans une minute,
le Tourist Trophy va commencer.
D'après la loi des probabilités,
il va gagner.
♪ aimerais qu'il remporte
la première course. Ça le motiverait.
S'il en gagne une,
il en gagnera deux ou trois autres.
♪ en suis certain.
Le premier pilote est prêt à partir,
il s'agit de Bruce Anstey.
Il y a encore du brouillard
sur Glencrutchery Road,
mais la course est lancée.
Il s'agit de l'engin de Bruce Anstey,
qui est déjà en train
de passer Union Mills,
suivi par John McGuinness,
l'homme le plus rapide
de l'histoire du circuit.
Et voici Hutchy, qui a remporté
deux victoires l'année dernière.
Le suivant est le numéro huit,
âgé de 28 ans,
Guy Martin, qui dévale Bray Hill.
Ça y est, on est parti.
John McGuinness a rattrapé Anstey.
McGuinness est en tête.
Le numéro six, Cameron Donald,
se rapproche de Keith Amor.
Cameron ne se laisse pas faire,
Cameron Donald reste devant.
Mais on voit venir Guy,
à toute vitesse.
John McGuinness a pris un très
bon départ,
mais Conor Cummins,
l'enfant du pays, le talonne,
avec seulement 8 centièmes
de secondes de retard.
Je vois sur mon écran que
Conor Cummins a pris la tête au niveau
de Ballaugh en temps compensé, il a trois
secondes d'avance sur McGuinness.
Mais apparemment,
John a des problèmes.
Il a passé Sulby à seulement 219 km/h.
Il y a sûrement quelque chose
qui cloche au niveau de sa moto.
A vous, Roy Moore.
C'est vraiment serré ici.
Guy Martin arrive.
Ça alors,
Michael Dunlop a failli dépasser
Guy Martin. Il s'en est fallu de peu.
Conor Cummins est en tête,
six secondes devant Ian Hutchinson.
Guy Martin est en troisième position,
une seconde derrière Hutchinson.
John McGuinness est hors course.
Quel dommage, le Roi de la Montagne
est éliminé au premier tour.
Mais le spectacle continue.
Que donne le classement ?
Conor Cummins a maintenant
14 secondes d'avance
sur Ian Hutchinson,
numéro quatre.
Pour la première fois
depuis plusieurs années,
un habitant de l'île
pourrait gagner.
Cummins est à 21 secondes, à présent.
S'il arrive à maintenir cette avance,
j'en connais qui vont faire la fête
ce soir.
Voici la vitesse moyenne de Hutchinson,
210,013 km/h.
Quant à Conor Cummins...
Il est à 211,646 km/h!
C'est une très belle performance.
Cameron Donald devrait arriver
à Cronk-ny-Mona d'une seconde à l'autre,
mais je ne vois personne.
Il a peut-être fait une erreur
un peu plus tôt,
peut-être au niveau de Signpost.
Ça expliquerait son retard.
Je vois venir Guy Martin,
qui vient faire son arrêt au stand.
Conor arrive au loin.
Il sait qu'il a 21 secondes
d'avance à Glen Helen.
C'est au tour d'Hutchinson.
Cameron doit se mordre les doigts
d'avoir fait cette erreur.
Il est maintenant 13e.
Conor a calé !
Il va réussir à repartir ?
La moto ne veut pas démarrer,
il perd du temps.
Allez !
Ça y est, elle a démarré !
C'est reparti pour Conor !
Guy quitte également le stand,
et il nous fait une superbe accélération.
A vous, Charlie.
Conor est passé de 21 à 4 secondes
d'avance.
17 secondes de perdues,
à cause de sa moto qui n'a pas voulu
démarrer tout de suite.
Il reste deux tours,
et rien n'est encore joué.
Cameron est bien décidé
à rattraper son retard sur Conor.
Conor Cummins, Ian Hutchinson,
Guy Martin et Michael Dunlop
sont en tête.
L'ordre est le même, mais le temps entre
les pilotes change considérablement.
A présent, voici les participants
suivants.
Nous avons Paul Dobbs,
avec son kiwi sur le casque.
Jenny s'élance également sur la piste.
Mais où est passé Conor ?
Conor Cummins
n'a pas atteint Glen Helen.
Je vois venir une moto au loin.
Non, ce n'est pas Conor,
c'est le numéro 8, Guy Martin.
Apparemment, Conor a disparu.
Non, Dave, on l'a retrouvé,
mais il est hors course. Il a subi
une défaillance mécanique
à Laurel Bank.
Une grosse déception
pour Conor Cummins.
C'est donc le numéro 4, Ian Hutchinson,
qui mène la course,
avec Guy Martin en seconde
position pour l'instant.
Je vois venir trois pilotes,
les uns derrière les autres.
Ça promet un sacré spectacle
dans les prochains virages.
Conor n'est pas le seul à avoir
eu des problèmes au stand.
On vient d'avoir cette info :
Guy Martin a pris
trente secondes de pénalité.
Il passe donc de la seconde
à la quatrième place.
Donc pas de podium pour l'instant.
Ian Hutchinson, le jeune pilote de 30 ans
originaire du Yorkshire,
est toujours en tête du Superbike TT.
Michael Dunlop est
en seconde position.
Hutchy va certainement gagner,
mais gardons un œil sur Cameron
qui a rattrapé le retard après son erreur
à Signpost, finissant en force.
La troisième place n'est pas gagnée.
Je vois qu'on sort le drapeau à damier.
Voici Ian Hutchinson
qui remporte la course.
Nous avons donc, dans l'ordre :
Hutchy, Dunlop et Donald.
Guy Martin est en quatrième position,
à cause d'une pénalité.
♪ étais à côté des stands,
et j'ai entendu
que Guy allait trop vite en traversant
les stands,
et qu'il aurait une pénalité.
C'est tout ce que je sais.
On a perdu la deuxième place.
Quand on l'a annoncé à Guy,
il est allé directement dans son van,
sans même retirer son casque.
Mais il va revenir.
C'est une énorme déception pour lui.
Il a parcouru les 360 kilomètres à fond,
et il reçoit une pénalité pour rien.
C'était seulement
une fraction de km/h de trop.
30 secondes de pénalité,
c'est vraiment sévère.
Il aurait dû en prendre cinq
à la rigueur.
On mesure la vitesse moyenne
sur une certaine distance.
Comment est-ce qu'ils peuvent
certifier que cette distance est précise
au millimètre près ?
Nous avons un règlement très détaillé.
Et il faut également préciser
que c'est le chef-chronométreur
qui est seul habilité
à prendre ces décisions.
Une fois qu'il a validé un certain
temps ou une certaine pénalité,
c'est sans appel.
Maintenant, il faut attendre
les prochaines courses.
Il y en aura deux lundi.
Il faut que Guy oublie la course
d'aujourd'hui.
Il y aura une autre Superbike vendredi.
Il faut passer à autre chose.
On est lundi, et deux
nouvelles courses se préparent,
dont une à 10h45,
avec les motos de 600 centimètres cube.
Guy Martin prend immédiatement la tête.
A Ballaugh, Guy Martin mène toujours
la course, juste une seconde
devant Ian Hutchinson.
Dan Kneen est en troisième position.
Guy conserve son avance à Ramsey.
Il semble bien décidé à ne pas perdre
de temps cette fois.
Mais Ian Hutchinson le rattrape
au Bungalow,
et prend la tête à la fin
du premier tour.
Guy Martin semble très à l'aise
entre les tribunes et le Bungalow,
c'est là qu'il est le plus rapide.
Mais sur le reste du circuit,
Hutchy a l'avantage.
C'est absolument fantastique.
Guy Martin mène la course.
Et Ian Hutchinson reprend l'avantage.
Guy Martin est à nouveau en tête.
Et Hutchy vient de le dépasser à nouveau.
C'était rapide !
Charlie, Guy a combien de retard ?
Il est à 3 secondes et 3 centièmes,
derrière Hutchy, sur l'arrêt au stand.
Les mécanos lui disent
qu'il peut y arriver,
et il y a sans doute des milliers
de gens qui aimeraient le lui dire aussi.
- Ecartez-vous !
- Y a-t-il un problème au stand ?
On entendait des cris.
Keith Amor est juste derrière Guy.
Michael Dunlop
passe en 3e position.
Ian Hutchinson a maintenant
quatre secondes d'avance
sur les autres. Mais Guy Martin
ne se laisse pas faire,
et il est en train de remonter
progressivement.
C'est bientôt la fin de la course
pour Hutchinson,
mais Guy Martin le rattrape,
c'est une performance extraordinaire !
Est-ce que ça lui permettra de gagner
une course du TT pour la première fois ?
Hutchy vient de franchir
la ligne d'arrivée.
Guy était parti 40 secondes après lui.
Le chronomètre est lancé.
Est-ce que Guy va faire
un meilleur temps que son adversaire ?
Trente-sept, trente-huit, trente-neuf.
Ian Hutchinson a gagné de
3 secondes et 3 centièmes.
Guy Martin est deuxième, et
Michael Dunlop est en troisième position.
Sur le podium, nous avons donc
Hutchinson, Martin et Dunlop.
A vous, Chris Kinley.
Guy n'est plus là.
Tim, tu sais où il est?
Il a quitté la piste,
c'est tout ce que je sais.
Il n'est pas allé rejoindre
les deux autres vainqueurs.
Je ne sais pas où il est parti,
il va falloir le retrouver.
Ce n'est pas la faute de Paul, Guy.
Il fait son boulot.
Ce n'est pas lui
qui a écrit le règlement.
Guy, on est fier de toi...
Fais-le pour Wilson, s'il te plaît.
Tu ne trouves pas ça frustrant ?
Oui, mais ce n'est pas une raison pour
- te venger sur ceux qui te soutiennent.
- 0,18 km/h !
Calme-toi, Guy, attends un peu !
Je te règle le micro.
Alors, où tu étais passé ?
0,18 km/h.
Vous voulez être capricieux ?
Je vais faire ce que je veux.
Tu parles de la course de samedi ?
Très bien, je te laisse y aller,
je te retrouverai plus tard.
Merci beaucoup.
Il va rejoindre les autres vainqueurs.
Guy Martin n'a pas tardé à exprimer
son mécontentement.
Si je marchais à 0,18 km/h,
j'irais loin, à votre avis ?
Vous voulez que je vous montre ?
Quelle blague. Trente secondes.
Ecoutez ça.
Ils ont bien mérité ces applaudissements.
C'était une course formidable,
et une chose est sûre,
ils ne sont pas près de l'oublier.
Mais Guy Martin
ne reste pas sur le podium,
il s'en va déjà. Il emmène sa bouteille
de champagne, par contre.
Comment vous vous sentez ?
Ils me cherchent, ils me trouvent.
Ils sont sans arrêt en train
de me gonfler,
"La presse ci, la presse ça."
Rien à foutre.
Ils me mettent des bâtons
dans les roues, moi je fais pareil.
C'est aussi simple que ça.
Et c'est que le début.
Attendez un peu que je gagne
une course.
Je n'ai même pas réfléchi.
♪ ai réagi purement par dépit.
Mais ça ne sert à rien.
♪ ai fait une interview hier matin,
et j'ai dit : "Je suis content
d'être quatrième,
c'est ce que je voulais."
Bien sûr que non.
Je voulais gagner.
Mais que voulez-vous
que je fasse ?
Ç'aurait pu être pire.
Au moins, on est toujours là.
Je me débrouille pas mal.
Mais pas assez bien,
puisque Hutchy m'a battu.
Je sais ce que j'ai à faire.
Il reste encore trois courses.
Ça va venir.
C'est Ryan Farquhar qui mène
la course, et il a l'air en pleine forme.
Guy a dû avoir un problème au départ,
il était loin derrière les dix premiers.
Hutchy gagne avec une seconde
et 3 centièmes d'avance,
suivi de Ryan et Conor.
C'est un magnifique coup du chapeau
pour Hutchy, trois victoires de suite.
Et il reste encore deux courses en solo.
♪ ai vraiment donné tout ce que j'avais.
C'est vraiment incroyable.
Allô ?
Salut.
Quoi de neuf ?
Non.
Je regarde des vidéos embarquées
pour mettre au point un plan d'attaque.
♪ ai celle de Jefferies en 2002,
et des passages filmés par Hutchy.
Je vais trop vite dans
les virages difficiles,
et je perds la course
sur les lignes droites.
Merci beaucoup.
- Signez ici.
- Bien sûr. Ça va ?
- Super.
- Bien.
- J'espère que vous allez gagner.
- Oui. Moi aussi.
Je suis avec Paul Dobbs.
- Bonjour ?
- Comment ça va ?
Que pensez-vous de la météo ?
Vous avez dû vous lever ce matin
- et vous dire : "Oh, non."
- Oui, mais peut-être que la course
- sera maintenue, si ça s'arrange.
- Très bien, Paul.
Je vous laisse vous préparer.
Vous vous sentez prêt pour la course ?
Pas du tout. Je ne peux pas y aller avec
un temps pareil. C'est trop dangereux.
Et voilà.
Guy, elle est amoureuse de toi !
Guy Marin est en quatrième position.
Hutchy arrive comme une fusée.
Keith Amor est troisième,
et Michael Dunlop mène la course,
mais de seulement
une seconde et 82 centièmes.
Moins de deux secondes d'avance !
Je crois que Hutchy a réussi.
Michael Dunlop passe
la ligne d'arrivée,
mais Ian Hutchinson a gagné la course
et plus.
Il vient de réaliser une performance
historique. Il est le premier pilote
à avoir gagné les quatre premières
courses du Trophy,
et le deuxième, après Phillip McCallen,
à avoir remporté
quatre courses en une semaine.
Ian Hutchinson est le nouveau Roi
de la Montagne.
Il n'y a aucun doute là-dessus.
James McBride est parti.
Ensuite, ce sera au tour de Paul Dobbs,
le pilote néo-zélandais,
suivi du Gallois Paul Owen.
Ça fait plaisir de le revoir sur le circuit.
Sur la ligne d'arrivée,
j'ai serré la main de Paul,
en lui souhaitant bonne chance.
Je devais attendre dix secondes
pour le suivre.
Il a démarré très vite.
Je l'ai vu s'éloigner et disparaître.
Je comptais chaque seconde.
On les entend descendre la pente,
puis remonter en accélérant à fond.
On sait tout de suite
si c'est un jeune ou pas.
Les plus âgés ont tendance
à rétrograder avant d'accélérer.
Ils passent soigneusement la vitesse,
et mettent les gaz.
Alors que les jeunes misent
uniquement sur l'accélération,
sans se servir de la boîte de vitesses.
Il a passé le virage,
mais il a touché le bord.
La moto a décollé.
Elle a atteint la même hauteur
que le sommet
de l'arrêt de bus qui est au coin.
On aurait dit un champ de bataille.
♪ étais en train de le rattraper,
à proximité de Ballagarey,
et je l'ai vu prendre le virage.
Quand j'ai aperçu les drapeaux jaunes,
je me suis dit:
"Soit son moteur a lâché,
soit il a eu un accident."
♪ entendais les autres pilotes approcher,
j'ai attrapé un drapeau
pour leur faire signe de ralentir.
Les médecins ont fait
tout ce qu'ils ont pu pour lui.
Mais je pense qu'il aurait choisi ça,
plutôt que de mourir en voiture
à cause d'un tracteur
qui l'aurait percuté, par exemple.
On est des pilotes.
On connaît les risques.
On est conscients
que ce n'est pas un jeu.
C'est pour ça qu'on s'entraide
chaque fois qu'on peut.
Et malheureusement, c'est un sport qui
peut coûter la vie aux vrais passionnés.
Paul en faisait partie.
A chaque Trophy, il y a un ou deux
moments où je bascule dans un état
très particulier durant chaque TT.
Tout autour de moi, je vois les gens,
les motos, les combinaisons.
J'entends la sirène de l'arrêt au stand.
Je baigne au milieu de tout ça,
et c'est un vrai bonheur.
Et ce jour-là, j'ai pensé :
"Ça me manquerait tout ça
s'il arrivait quelque chose à Dobbsy."
Et une heure plus tard...
On peut perdre ceux qu'on aime
à tout moment.
Il suffit de se faire heurter
par un bus en traversant la rue.
On en parle souvent, on plaisante
entre nous. Les pilotes disent :
"Je ne sais pas si je serai là
la semaine prochaine."
Mais quand on a ça à l'esprit,
même à un niveau subconscient,
on savoure vraiment la vie.
On apprécie d'autant plus les gens
qu'on aime,
leurs particularités,
et la chance qu'on a.
On participe à ces courses uniquement
pour s'amuser.
C'est la seule raison.
Il faut profiter de la vie
autant qu'on peut.
Et on veut partager ça
avec nos enfants.
Ils nous accompagnent,
ils adorent ça, ça fait partie d'eux.
C'est les moments qu'on a vécus
ensemble qui ont fait d'eux
ce qu'ils sont aujourd'hui.
Ils sont formidables.
Ce sont des enfants très forts,
très drôles.
On s'amuse énormément.
Et ça, ça ne change pas.
On s'amusera, quoi qu'il arrive.
On fait de la moto, on met
de la musique, on danse dans la cuisine.
Et on aime toujours le Trophy.
Ça non plus, ça ne change pas.
La mort, la perte,
c'est vraiment terrible.
Mais ça fait partie intégrante de la course,
et de ce qu'elle nous fait vivre.
On le sait tous.
Ce ne serait pas aussi grisant,
s'il ‘y avait pas cette part de risque.
C'est pour ça qu'ils y participent.
Nous avons reçu la confirmation
qu'un deuxième pilote
est décédé pendant la course d'hier.
Martin Loicht, un Autrichien de 48 ans,
a perdu la vie à Quarry Bends.
On est vendredi. C'est le jour de la
Senior, la dernière course du Trophy.
C'est la course la plus importante
de l'année. Le gros lot.
Pour le vainqueur,
c'est la gloire assurée.
C'est considérable.
On va tous se donner à fond.
Tout le monde est prêt.
Guy est à la hauteur.
C'est lui qui vient d'arriver,
C'est lui.
Avec son vieux vélo plein de terre.
Qui gagnera ?
Si Ian Hutchinson remporte
sa cinquième course,
ce serait un exploit sensationnel.
Est-ce que John McGuinness
montera sur le podium ?
♪ ai fait deuxième, j'ai fait quatrième hier,
et cinquième l'autre jour.
Pas terrible, comme semaine.
J'ai eu beaucoup de problèmes
sur la configuration de la moto.
Mais ça donne matière à réfléchir.
Je dois jouer le jeu
et faire de mon mieux sur le circuit.
On verra bien ce que ça donnera.
Je ferai tout mon possible.
Je passe mon temps
à regarder les vidéos du parcours,
pour me préparer le mieux possible.
Mais des fois, je me dis
que peut-être que j'en fais trop,
et que ça me bloque.
Il va falloir que j'y aille franchement.
Cette histoire de pénalité
n'était pas si grave que ça.
Ç'aurait pu être pire.
Mais quand on m'a annoncé ça,
tout habillé sur le circuit...
Si j'avais croisé le mec
qui a mesuré mon excès de vitesse,
je l'aurais massacré.
Mais en fait, je vous jure,
je l'aurais démoli.
Je ne suis pas du genre violent,
mais il y a des limites à tout.
Sur un évènement pareil,
zéro virgule...
C'est une blague.
♪ ai gagné quatre courses. Ce serait
formidable de gagner la cinquième.
Ce serait vraiment le rêve.
Mais évidemment, ils vont tous
faire de leur mieux pour me battre.
Même si je trouve que d'un certain côté,
ils s'en voudront moins
si une seule personne gagne
toutes les courses.
Ils ne peuvent rien y faire.
Ce n'est pas comme
s'il y avait quatre gagnants,
mais qu'ils ne l'étaient pas.
Je trouve qu'il y a moins de pression
dans le cas présent.
Mais en même temps, c'est
la dernière course pour cette année.
S'ils veulent vraiment remporter
une victoire au Trophy,
c'est leur seule chance.
Je pense que beaucoup de gens
vont encourager Conor Cummins,
l'enfant du pays,
pour la dernière course du Trophy.
Il ne faut pas que je sois énervé.
Ecouter du métal à fond,
ce n'est pas la bonne stratégie.
Je vais plutôt écouter un peu
de musique soul.
Et fumer une dizaine de cigarettes.
- Vous en pensez quoi ?
- Ça t'aiderait ?
Oui, mais je ne dois pas fumer.
Je reprendrai la cigarette après juillet.
Au cours des deux dernières semaines,
j'ai eu très envie, plusieurs fois...
Mais j'ai résisté.
J'écoute un peu d'Otis Redding,
et je fais semblant de fumer...
et je prends les choses
comme elles viennent.
Le tour de formation se termine.
Il ne reste plus qu'une heure
avant le lancement de la course Senior
du Tourist Trophy, à 12h30.
Nous vous tiendrons au courant de tout
et vous ferons partager
les interviews des pilotes.
Est-ce que Ian Hutchinson
va entrer dans |'Histoire ?
Il a amplement prouvé son talent
sur ce parcours.
Et voici le numéro 1, Bruce Anstey.
John McGuinness
détient toujours le record de vitesse
par tour avec une moyenne
de 211,754 km/h.
Moins de 10 secondes avant le départ.
De l'autre côté de Glencrutchery Road,
j'aperçois les fans de Guy Martin,
qui reste l'un des grands favoris,
de même que Conor Cummins,
numéro 10.
Plus que quelques secondes.
Tous les yeux fixent le drapeau,
et c'est parti.
Bruce Anstey. John McGuinness.
Ian Lougher.
Hutchy avec le numéro quatre.
Keith Amor.
Cameron Donald.
Michael sur Honda,
suivi de Guy Martin.
C'est Guy Martin qui est en tête.
Mais je vois sur mon écran
qu'il n'a que 4 ou 5 dixièmes
de seconde d'avance
sur Conor Cummins, numéro 10.
Ian Hutchinson est seulement à
6 centièmes de seconde derrière
Cummins, et c'est ensuite
John McGuinness, le numéro 2,
à 74 centièmes de seconde.
Les quatre premiers se tiennent
dans un intervalle de seulement
une seconde et demie.
Guy Martin attaque la ligne droite.
Sa vitesse moyenne au premier
tour vient d'être mesurée :
210,998 km/h,
un nouveau record personnel pour Guy,
décidément en très grande forme.
Le duel commence entre les numéros
8 et 10,
Guy Martin et Conor Cummins.
Ils mènent la course,
mais Hutchy et John McGuinness
ne sont pas loin derrière.
Conor a pris la tête,
il a dépassé Guy Martin,
mais il n'a que 58 centièmes d'avance.
Ça se joue à une fraction de seconde.
Guy Martin a réduit l'écart,
il n'y a plus qu'un dixième
de seconde de différence
entre Cummins et lui.
La lutte est extrêmement serrée.
Je viens d'apercevoir Guy Martin,
c'est une vraie fusée.
Regardez sa vitesse !
Voici les nouveaux résultats
de Guy Martin.
210,248 km/h.
Il menait à Cronk-ny-Mona.
On attend maintenant l'arrivée
de Conor. Le voilà.
209,662 km/h.
Ils ont fini de changer le pneu de Guy,
et il est parti !
Un très bel arrêt au stand
réalisé par l'équipe de Wilson Craig.
Conor Cummins
est presque prêt à partir.
Ça y est, Cummins
repart à toute vitesse !
C'est reparti.
Et voilà Guy Martin !
On a constaté un intervalle
étrangement long
entre Hutchinson, Michael Dunlop
et Keith Amor.
Pendant quelques secondes,
la route est silencieuse.
On attend toujours le numéro 8.
C'est Conor Cummins,
le numéro 10.
Nous n'avons pas vu Guy Martin.
Il a disparu.
Attention, drapeau rouge.
On ne sait pas trop ce qui se passe.
La course a été arrêtée
pour permettre
aux pompiers d'intervenir.
Quelque chose de grave
est arrivé à Ballagarey.
En cent ans, c'est la deuxième fois
qu'une course Senior est interrompue.
Incident à Ballagarey.
Guy Martin n'a pas atteint Glen Helen.
Ils ont sorti le drapeau rouge.
On pense que Guy a eu un accident,
et que sa moto a pris feu.
C'est l'un des seuls motifs pour
lesquels la course peut être interrompue.
Tout le monde a l'estomac noué.
Les mécaniciens de l'équipe
de Wilson Craig font les cent pas.
Ils sont nerveux.
Ils n'en savent pas plus que nous.
On a entendu dire que Guy
avait disparu avant d'atteindre Glen Helen.
On préfère dire que c'est une défaillance
mécanique plutôt qu'un accident.
Ensuite, on a entendu parler
d'une haie en feu à Glen Vine.
A part les pilotes et les employés,
nous demandons à tout le monde
de quitter le parc fermé. Merci.
On voyait le feu à plus d'un kilomètre.
Les employés m'ont fait signe
de ralentir.
En passant devant, j'ai vu que c'était
une botte de foin qui avait pris feu.
♪ ai vu la moto couchée par terre.
Je me suis dit:
"J'ai passé la zone de l'incident."
Et un demi-kilomètre plus loin,
j'ai vu Guy.
Là, j'ai pensé : "Merde."
Il y a eu un incident. Guy avait disparu,
donc c'était forcément lui.
Il a percuté quelque chose,
et il roulait sans doute
à plus de 270 km/h.
Quand on est éjecté à plus
de 270 km/h,
on ne s'en relève pas.
On est très inquiet.
C'est là que Paul Dobbs a eu
son accident, et il n'a pas survécu.
On croise les doigts pour Guy,
et on espère qu'il a eu plus de chance.
On ne peut rien faire d'autre,
à part attendre.
Il a dû faire une petite erreur de pilotage,
et il a percuté un mur.
Ça se présente mal.
Quand je suis passé sur le lieu,
on aurait dit qu'une bombe avait explosé.
Le mur et les bottes
de foin étaient en feu,
et Guy était couché sur la route,
avec la moto en plusieurs morceaux.
C'était atroce.
Alors, on croise les doigts,
et on attend des nouvelles.
Le nouveau départ sera donné à 15h00,
pour une course Senior de quatre tours.
C'est comme ça.
On est tous volontaires,
personne ne nous menace.
On adore cette course,
et si jamais les choses tournent mal
et que le pire se produit,
au moins, on meurt heureux.
En attendant, le spectacle continue.
On repart sur quatre tours complets,
et la vitesse sera toujours aussi élevée.
Voici les conditions actuelles. La route
manque d'adhérence à Ballagarey.
Le reste du parcours est sec.
La visibilité est bonne.
Course en quatre tours.
Je croise les doigts pour Conor.
Je sais qu'il nous offrira encore
un spectacle magnifique,
et s'il m'entend,
je te soutiens à fond.
Quatre tours.
242,88 kilomètres.
John McGuinness part en premier.
Il menait la course au moment
de l'interruption.
Voici Ian Hutchinson.
Conor Cummins, qui se débrouille
très bien jusqu'à présent,
il doit maintenir l'effort pendant
toute la durée de la course.
Je vois passer McGuinness,
qui a pris une petite avance.
Il précède Hutchy de 61 centièmes
de seconde.
Je suis au regret d'annoncer
que Michael n'est plus dans la course,
et Cameron descend de moto.
Voici maintenant Conor, très déterminé.
Nous sommes à Glen Helen,
pour le deuxième tour.
Apparemment,
McGuinness a abandonné la course.
Ian Hutchinson est en tête, avec
3 secondes et 24 centièmes d'avance
sur Conor Cummins.
Nous avons des nouvelles
du Bungalow.
Ian Hutchinson est toujours en tête.
On attend l'arrivée
de Conor pour savoir
quelle est l'avance de Hutchy.
Conor a chuté au niveau de la véranda,
et on s'occupe de lui.
Ian Hutchinson franchit la ligne d'arrivée,
et achève une performance historique.
En une semaine, il a gagné les cinq
courses du Tourist Trophy.
C'est extraordinaire.
Le jeune pilote de 30 ans
vient de réécrire
l'histoire de l'un des plus
grands évènements motocyclistes
du monde.
On l'a entendu arriver à toute vitesse,
le moteur à fond.
Il a franchi le virage.
Sa trajectoire était superbe,
il faut lui reconnaître ça.
Mais il a perdu le contrôle.
La moto est tombée à terre,
et à l'impact,
elle s'est transformée en
une véritable boule de feu.
C'est comme le générique
d'une série télé ou d'un film d'action
avec les flammes
qui remplissent l'écran,
et une silhouette qu'on distingue
par-dessus, c'est Guy.
Je me suis dit : "Ça y est,
il faut qu'on y aille". Ça m'a frappé.
♪ ai ramassé ma trousse
de premiers secours,
et j'ai vu Guy passer en vol
plané devant moi,
suivi par la moto en flammes.
Elle s'est écrasée sur le côté,
avec de la fumée partout.
On ne voyait presque plus rien.
Et Guy était au milieu de tout ça.
Je lui ai dit : "Je ne découpe pas
ton cuir, je t'examine d'abord."
Il me répond :
"Non, ne le découpe pas."
Je comprends ça,
je suis un motard aussi,
et je ne voudrais surtout pas
qu'on découpe mon cuir.
Mais il allait bien, il s'en était sorti.
Il devait sûrement y avoir
quelqu'un qui veillait sur lui.
Il a eu de la chance.
Je me suis dit:
"Ça se passe plutôt bien."
Je suis passé de zéro
à 211 km/h.
♪ ai un peu perdu sur la vitesse
moyenne au moment de l'arrêt au stand.
Je me battais pour rester en tête.
En sortant du stand,
j'ai bien tenu jusqu'à Glen Vine.
Je menais.
Je pensais pouvoir continuer.
♪ ai eu des moments pareils.
♪ avais une bonne adhérence.
Et j'ai atteint ce point
où on sent que ça tient,
mais qu'on ne peut pas aller plus loin.
♪ étais reparti du stand avec
un réservoir plein, et j'avais imaginé
que je conserverais suffisamment
d'adhérence à ce moment-là.
Mais apparemment, non.
Je pense que le réservoir plein
a changé la donne.
♪ ai perdu le contrôle.
C'est l'un des virages
les plus rapides du circuit.
Je devais être à 260 ou 270.
Je me disais :
"C'est bon, je l'ai.
Non je l'ai pas."
J'ai dû sauter de la moto.
♪ ai évité le plus gros de l'incendie.
Je me suis seulement un peu brûlé
les sourcils,
et la frange,
comme vous pouvez voir.
Etj'ai dû me prendre le mur.
C'est très flou, j'étais dans les vapes.
Mais je m'en suis sorti.
Je vais plutôt bien.
Ç'aurait pu être largement pire.
En fait, je n'ai rien.
J'ai juste les genoux à vif,
en glissant à 260 à l'heure.
♪ ai pas mal de brûlures
à cause de la friction.
Des côtes cassées,
un poumon perforé.
Quatre vertèbres déplacées,
et deux vertèbres cassées.
A part ça, je suis comme neuf.
Alors je suis tranquillement allongé,
je remue les jambes,
et je me dis que je suis invincible.
Etj'essaie de me lever, et :
"En fait, non,
ça ne va pas si bien que ça."
Avec la colonne vertébrale,
il ne faut pas se précipiter.
Pour l'instant, la fracture est stable,
mais si je force trop,
ça peut s'aggraver.
Conor est un peu plus loin dans le couloir,
et ça n'a pas l'air bon.
Son dos est dans un état bien pire.
Ils vont l'envoyer dans un autre hôpital,
pour lui mettre une vis entre l'épaule
et le coude.
Mais c'est le jeu.
On connaît les risques.
Personne ne nous oblige à le faire.
C'est comme ça.
Si c'était à refaire, je referais
exactement la même chose.
Exactement.
Mais ce n'est que partie remise.
Je vais en baver un peu,
mais ça passera.
♪ y arriverai.
Je crois que je suis monté sur
le podium tous les ans depuis 1997,
alors ça fait bizarre d'avancer
le long de la piste,
et de ne pas entendre
les applaudissements.
♪ étais en tête de la première course,
et après, tout est allé de travers.
Pour la Senior,
la course au ruban bleu,
j'avais environ 11 secondes d'avance,
jusqu'à l'accident de Guy.
On a arrêté la course,
puis on est repartis à zéro.
Il fallait à nouveau se préparer,
se concentrer.
Ça s'annonçait plutôt bien
après le départ, et là,
j'ai eu une défaillance
au niveau du coupe-circuit.
Un câble s'est détaché,
la soudure a lâché,
et je me suis retrouvé complètement
hors jeu.
Mais c'est ça, le Trophy.
♪ ai eu beaucoup de chance pendant
des années, j'ai gagné beaucoup
de courses, mais la roue tourne
un jour ou l'autre.
Et encore, je m'en tire bien
par rapport à Guy Martin,
ou encore par rapport à
Conor Cummins.
Je suis encore en un seul morceau.
Je vais rentrer chez moi,
remettre de l'ordre dans mes idées,
et voir les possibilités qui s'offrent
à moi pour l'année prochaine. Si je ne
le sens pas, peut-être que j'arrêterai.
On ne sait jamais.
Avec les enfants,
il y a eu des moments difficiles.
Je n'ai pas essayé de leur cacher
quoi que ce soit,
et on a beaucoup pleuré ensemble.
Et puis après, on s'est dit :
"On fait quoi ?"
On essaie de passer à autre chose.
Je pense qu'il faut profiter de la vie.
Apprécier ce qu'on a, tant qu'on l'a.
On ne choisit pas ce que
la vie nous donne,
mais on peut choisir
d'en profiter ou pas.
Je suis retourné sur le lieu
de mon accident.
Il y a encore des traces de peinture
verte sur le sol, là où ma moto a glissé.
♪ ai vu l'endroit précis
où j'ai perdu le contrôle,
et là où je me suis retrouvé
après ma chute.
♪ ai contemplé cet endroit, et j'ai repensé
aux blessures que j'ai subies.
C'est un peu démoralisant.
Le pire, c'est mon dos,
cinq fractures,
et une grosse cicatrice
à cause des obstacles que j'ai percutés
en dégringolant le long de la pente.
♪ ai aussi quatre fractures au bras,
avec des lésions nerveuses,
mais ça se rétablit bien.
Je me suis déboîté le genou,
j'ai quelques égratignures,
une fracture au pelvis et à l'omoplate,
et un poumon endommagé.
Il m'a fallu un certain temps
pour accepter tout ça,
pour me faire à cette idée.
C'est un processus difficile.
Mais je ne vais pas abandonner.
♪ ai 24 ans, et je reconnais
que j'ai eu de la chance,
mais j'aime toujours autant
les courses de moto,
et j'ai des objectifs à atteindre.
Dès que je peux, j'y retourne.
C'est mon plan.
Retourner là où je suis tombé
au prochain TT ou à mon retour,
je prends le virage comme d'habitude.
C'était violent comme accident.
Mais la vie continue.
Le monde ne s'est pas arrêté
de tourner pour moi.
Un magnifique départ.
Je crois que Ian Hutchinson qui a gagné
les cinq courses du TT en une semaine.
est celui qui est tombé.
C'est vraiment pas de chance.
J'ai eu un accident pendant
l'une des dernières courses de l'année,
sur un petit circuit. Voilà le résultat.
C'était plutôt grave comme accident.
Je me suis fait rouler dessus.
Ils ont dit qu'ils allaient peut-être
devoir m'amputer. J'ai dit non.
Je ne pensais qu'à une chose,
j'ai besoin de ma jambe
pour continuer à faire de la moto.
C'est tout ce qui compte pour moi.
Je voulais récupérer mon pied.
Et pas seulement un pied inerte
au bout de la jambe.
Je voulais un pied 100 % fonctionnel
pour pouvoir continuer mon métier.
C'est arrivé pile au bon moment,
quand j'y pense.
La saison reprend dans 7 mois.
Il va falloir que je reprenne
l'entraînement pour me préparer
à la première course
de l'année prochain.